so far on cloud storage bytes we've
talked about managing object data
through renaming moving and deleting but
there's another facet of managing
objects that's equally important
managing metadata today we'll take a
look at what metadata is available in a
cloud storage object and how it's used
let's get started
metadata identifies properties of a
cloud storage object and specifies how
the object should be handled when it's
accessed metadata exists as key value
pairs the mutability of metadata varies
some metadata you can edit at any time
some metadata you can only set at the
time the object is created and some
metadata you can only view so first
let's talk about editable metadata there
are two categories of metadata that are
editable by users fixed key metadata and
custom metadata with fixed key metadata
the keys are set but you can specify a
value with custom metadata you have to
specify both a key and a value you can
edit this list of fixed key metadata
values for objects if you have
sufficient permission to do so Cloud
Storage uses Identity and Access
Management and access control lists to
control access to objects including
access to the objects metadata if you'd
like to know more about access control
check out our episode and the related
documentation the cache-control metadata
can specify two different aspects of how
data is served from cloud storage if it
can be cached
and if it can be transformed I won't say
more about cache control here because
that'll be enough for a future video but
you can also find out more in the
documentation linked below the
content-disposition metadata specifies
presentation information about the data
being transmitted setting
content-disposition allows you to
control the presentation of style of the
content for example determining whether
an attachment should be automatically
displayed or whether some form of action
from the user should be required to open
it check the links in the description to
see the content-disposition
specification the content encoding
metadata can be used to indicate that an
object is compressed while still
maintaining the objects underlying
content type for example a text file
that is gzip compressed can have the
fact that it's a text file indicated in
the content type and the fact that it's
gzip compressed indicated in content
encoding the
language metadata indicates the language
or languages that the object is intended
for refer to iso 639 - 1 language codes
for the supported values of this
metadata the most commonly set metadata
is content type also known as media type
this allows browsers to render the
object properly all objects of a value
specified in their content type metadata
but this value does not have to match
the underlying type of the object for
example if the content type isn't
specified when the object gets uploaded
and it's not a common data type chances
are it's gonna be something generic or
just wrong in the metadata custom
metadata are like standard metadata
except you can specify custom metadata
key value pairs to create custom
metadata you specify both of value and a
key once you have created a custom
metadata key value pair you can delete
the key or change the value you can edit
fixed key and custom metadata from the
rest api GS util and the cloud platform
console let's take a look at the console
open the cloud storage browser in the
cloud platform console in the list of
buckets click on the name of the bucket
that contains the desired object and
navigate to the object click the three
dots for more options associated with
the object click Edit metadata in the
overlay window that appears make the
desired edits to the metadata for
standard metadata fields edit the value
add your own custom metadata by clicking
the plus sign add item button you can
edit both the key and a value of your
custom metadata delete your custom
metadata by clicking the associated X
finally click Save and now you know how
to edit metadata from the console but
some metadata can't be edited directly
this metadata is set at the time of
object creation or rewrite as part of
the object creation or rewrite you can
set some such metadata such as the
storage class of the object or customer
supplied encryption keys other metadata
is automatically
and can only be viewed such as the
generation number of the object or the
time of creation find out more on the
docs linked below there's clearly a lot
more you can do about metadata but
that's for a totally different episode
if you want to know about how cloud
storage uses metadata check out the
links in the description don't forget to
subscribe give us a like and tell us
what you want to learn about Google
Cloud storage thanks for joining us for
this quick byte of cloud storage see you
next time
[Music]